die nasa stellt ein russischer
kampfroboter und sternenexplosion 570
milliarden mal so hell wie unsere sonne
das sind nur drei der fünf themen in den
klicks und top 50 wasser auf dem
zwergplaneten cscs ist ein zwergplanet
und der befindet sich im
asteroidengürtel zwischen mars und
jupiter der nasa gelang es anfang des
jahres eine aufnahme von cs mit hilfe
der raumsonde dawn zu schießen und in
einem krater entdeckten die forscher
zwei helle flecken und waren sich
zunächst nicht sicher
um was es sich dabei handeln könnte erst
kürzlich klärten die forscher des
max-planck-instituts für
sonnensystemforschung in götting wie
diese hellen flecken entstehen
salzablagerungen jetzt machen sie
allerdings eine neue entdeckung auf cs
existiert gefrorenes wasser
das besondere daran ist dass in diesem
wasser ablagerung salze zu finden sind
dies auch auf der erde gibt diese neue
entdeckung konnten die wissenschaftler
anhand neuer und sehr detailreiche
bilder der raumsonde dawn machen auf den
bildern entspricht 1 pixel rund 35 meter
das klingt erst mal ziemlich ungenau ist
aber für eine fotografie aus dem all
äusserst genau übrigens die sonde dawn
bleibt noch bis zum 30
juli 2016 aktiv danach wird sie nicht
zur erde zurückgeholt sondern bleibt bei
cs ob und was die forscher mit ihr nach
dem 30 juli vorhaben das ist noch nicht
bekannt 570 milliarden mal so hell wie
unsere sonder letzten samstag hatten wir
noch darüber gesprochen wann wird es
gelingen sternexplosionen die milliarden
mal so hell sind wie die sonne
aufzuzeichnen eine woche später ist es
dann schon passiert experten ist es
tatsächlich gelungen die supernova sn 15
lh aufzuzeichnen zitat usa
ssn 15 lh ist die gewaltigste supernova
die in der menschheitsgeschichte
entdeckt worden ist so der astronom su
tong vom kavli institut für astronomie
und astrophysik an der universität
peking die 3,8 milliarden lichtjahre
entfernte supernovas eignete sich schon
im juni 2015
als die forscher die aufnahmen mit dem
south african large telescope kurz zollt
respekt
bereich analysierten viel sie ihnen erst
auf zitat als sich die spektralen
signaturen von sol sah und mir klar
wurde dass wir die bislang gewaltigste
supernova entdeckt hatten war ich den
rest der nacht zu aufgeregt zum schlafen
so wurden im fachmagazin science
die forscher sprachen neben dem erfolg
auch über das unwissen über die
energiequelle solche explosionen mit den
neuen aufnahmen könnte das aber bald
nicht mehr zu den ungeklärten
wissenschaftlichen fragen gehören
planetare verteidigung soll uns vor
asteroiden schützen um die erde kreisen
ja so einige dinge satelliten schrott
aber natürlich kommen uns auch
asteroiden oft gefährlich nah und
kollidieren auch mit der erde vor rund
einem jahr veröffentlichte die stiftung
pies 611 ein video in dem 26 einschlags
orte gezeigt wurden haben darüber
berichtet
damals machte der astronaut adblue
deutlich wie groß die gefahr eines
solchen anschlags sei rund eine million
asteroiden mit dem prozent potenzial
eine ganze stadt zu zerstören befinden
sich in unserem sonnensystem sagte er
die nasa hat sich dem problem jetzt
gestellt sie gründete das planetary die
fans coordination office kurz wie dies
soll eine schnittstelle zwischen
verschiedenen ländern darstellen und
projekte betreffend der asteroiden und
kometen forschung koordinieren neben
diesen informationen teilte die
us-weltraumagentur auch mit dass die esa
parallel dazu mit der nase an einem
abwehrsystem arbeitet das asteroiden vor
einem einschlag zerstören soll die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass es auf der erde
zu großen schäden durch solche
einschläge kommen könnte kann durch
diese arbeit also reduziert werden
russischer kampfroboter soll bei der
terrorbekämpfung helfen
nach den letzten terroristischen
ereignissen er in europa ist die
terrorbekämpfung ein ganz wichtiges
thema wie kann man effektiv gegen
terrorismus vorgehen russische
ingenieure des roboterherstellers
lobinzew haben jetzt einen kampfroboter
vorgestellt der helfen soll die gefahr
des terrors zu unterbinden
vom aussehen her ähnelt die maschine
stark an in afghanistan eingesetzte
roboter für kampfmittelbeseitigung
sogenannte bombe
trotz der mini rex hat allerdings noch
einiges mehr hier kommt ein kurzer
ausschnitt das ganze video findet er in
der video beschreibung
die nasa stellt ein und das deutsche
zentrum für luft und raumfahrt kurze lr
sucht auch zwölf männliche probanden die
sich dazu bereit erklären zwei monate
lang am stück im bett zu liegen ja super
job inklusive mehrerer darauffolgender
nachuntersuchungen natürlich im dienste
der wissenschaft die forscher des dlr
wollen so herausfinden wie sich die
schwerelosigkeit auf den physiologischen
zustand des menschen auswirkt die
schwerelosigkeit wird mit einer 6 grad
kopf schieflage und bettruhe simuliert
die schiefe körperlage bringt den
flüssigkeitshaushalt im körper
durcheinander sodass es reaktionen gibt
wie in der schwerelosigkeit und die
probanden sollen sich möglichst nicht
bewegen und deshalb den ganz einfachen
grund dass die muskeln im weltall auch
kaum beansprucht werden auch die nasa
sucht neues personal allerdings keine
probanden für versuche auf der erde
sondern astronauten
einsendeschluss für die bewerbungen ist
der 18 februar und was sind die
voraussetzungen können wir alle
astronauten werden
ich glaube nicht es müsse nämlich ein
paar kriterien erfüllt werden eine ist
die potenziellen absolut müssen die us
bürger schafft besitzen und in den
studiengängen wie beispielsweise
mathematik physik oder
ingenieurwissenschaften einen abschluss
haben und auf dem gebiet dann so
mindestens drei jahre gearbeitet haben
ja und 1000 flugstunden als pilot sollen
sie auch absolviert haben also ziemlich
hohe anforderungen aber was würdet ihr
machen wenn er sie erfüllen würde würdet
ihr euch bewerben und wenn ja welche
aufgaben würde er gerne übernehmen ja ab
in die kommentare damit vergesst nicht
den kanal zu abonnieren ist er kostenlos
das nächste video gucken ist wie immer
spannend und ansonsten bis dann bleibt
dran